as we've already talked about as we exit
the 1800s and we get into the early
1900s and we approach World War one the
various powers of Europe were really on
this race for Empire was a part of
national prestige and it helped build
national wealth but of the major powers
Germany and Italy were relatively new as
unified States the British Empire they
had been building their empire for
hundreds of years the Germans on the
other hand even though they have a very
old culture going back hundreds or you
could argue thousands of years as a
unified state they only existed since
1871 and that's only after the
franco-prussian war which allowed the
Prussians to unify all of Germany and
the Italians only became fully unified
in 1870 also due to the franco-prussian
war because the French had to focus on
the Germans had to focus on the
Prussians they couldn't protect the
papal States anymore and so that allowed
the Italians to unify it under their
rule so by the time we get to 1914 the
beginning of world war one these two
powers they were also on the race for
Empire but there are only about 43 or 44
years old and so they hadn't been able
to build as extensive of an empire as
France and especially as an extensive of
an empire as Great Britain but this map
right over here shows where what was the
extent of their well how far their
actual empires did extend Italy had
control of Libya Eritrea and parts of
what's today Somalia and Germany had
control also it also had had had
holdings in Africa possessions in Africa
Togoland which is modern-day Togo
Cameroon which makes up which is
modern-day Cameroon as part of german
south-west africa that's now known as
namibia german east africa which is now
Tanzania Rwanda and Burundi and Germany
also had holdings in Pacific in the
Pacific and even in China these are the
the Pacific Islands that Germany had
possession of and had German New Guinea
and it even had it even had control of
the town of Tsing Tao that actually is
culturally interesting for those of you
watching this video in 2013 Tsing Tao is
now a very popular
Chinese brand of beer one of the more I
think it's the number two in the in the
market Chinese beer and and its
associated with China but it was
actually started by German settlers in
Tsingtao in 1903 so this is actually its
roots are with Germans who obviously
have a long tradition of producing beers
and so Tsingtao you could argue it's a
Chinese beer it's produced in China but
it had its roots in kind of German
imperial rule